my advice to other musician
first and foremost would be to make
music that they love because if you
spend your life working on something
that you love and you never have success
with it well at least you spent your
life doing something that you love and
by doing something that you love you
vastly improve the chances that you will
have success with it is the worst case
scenario is to give up your entire life
to work on something that you don't love
and end up having no success with it so
then at the end of your life you look
back and you say oh I compromised and
had no success
so basically make music that you love
and be open minded and your approach to
other people's music if I think a lot of
people a lot of musicians a lot of
artists in general tend to be very rigid
when evaluating other you know other
people's music or other people's art and
and then simple things like work hard
and be diligent and don't drink too much
and don't take too many drugs and allow
yourself to be influenced by interesting
other you know other interesting
musicians and study the history of music
because I think a lot of contemporary
musicians their understanding of music
goes back 20 years or 30 years and
that's just sort of a shame because you
know I think musicians do their best
work when you think of George Gershwin
and Rhapsody and blue the the
inspiration for that and the influences
for that are so diverse and going you
know going back fifty to a hundred years
before he was actually writing it and
that's one of the reasons have such a
powerful piece of music